[Musique]
au cégep de drummondville
les jeunes du programme de musique
viennent d'un peu partout au québec du
nouveau brunswick même de la france mais
l'an dernier il s'était surtout devant
leur ordinateur à la maison
[Musique]
les leçons de solfège à distance sont un
défi même pour les meilleurs oreille
musicale
citons louis borg et betty sa bonne peut
pas continuer vraiment coach veut pas
avoir pas entendre précisément et où
l'erreur est ce que tu as échoué dès qu
on a abandonné ouais ouais ouais
j'échoue et des cours est-ce que tu as
un moment donné était à décourager au
point de songer du juste abandonné cégep
oui complètement
notre toute la signification vient dans
le partage qu'on fait de notre à avec le
public avec nos collègues alors être
tout seul dans ma chambre devoir rester
motivé a engagé une carrière en musique
ce qui est déjà déjà assez courageux et
téméraires officiellement le nombre
d'échecs n'a pas augmenté dans les
cégeps parce qu'au début de la pandémie
le ministère a permis les abandons
jusqu'à la fin des cours cela permet aux
étudiants d'avoir un incomplet au lieu
d'un échec ce sont donc les abandons de
cours qui ont explosé de 500%
hier français que j'ai échoué une fois
puis c'était parce que j'avais vraiment
trop de choses dans mon frère on a quand
même tout fait extension avec quel degré
on va mettre une seule file on y est
moins loin que normalement et moi je me
disais j'ai pas envie de traîner de la
patte tout le long de mon université
parce que on est un peu en arrière à
cause de ça donc j'ai décidé de prendre
plus de temps si j'ai pu finalement
j'avoue que c'est touchant d'entendre ça
mais ce qui m'est arrivé en retard à
l'université c'est du sénat dit parce
que deux possibilités de rattraper puis
au niveau de l'oreille humaine de
l'oreille musicale mais ça se développe
à long terme
il ya une anxiété je ne peux plaçons
étudiants qu'ils ont à tort ou à raison
la perception chez certains de ne pas
avoir tout ce qu'il faut pour continuer
outre cégep autres programmes même trou
dans les apprentissages les jeunes
arrivent et du secondaire l'automne
dernier ont des retards marquer surtout
en français en mathématiques et en
sciences pour certains cette session
elle est beaucoup plus difficile genre
j'ai beaucoup de retard et j'arrive pas
à rattraper mon retard donc je dois
travailler plus de la moitié de l'année
en cinquième secondaire s'est passé en
mode virtuel rendu au cégep les retards
sont parfois difficiles à rattraper même
pour les bons étudiants la première
session c'était rocheuses j'ai joué
quelques courses accueilli en train de
les reprendre
oui ça se fait que ça ça m'a pris par
choc j'étais un peu en dépression à
cause de ça mais c'est la vie on vous
demander de venir me voir avec votre
tube de me montrer d'embarras augustin
dit qu'elle n'a jamais eu autant
d'encadrement à faire les étudiants sont
désorganisés beaucoup de pertes de
mémoire par rapport aux dates d'échéance
comment s'organise avec les différents
documents les différentes plateformes
alors je trouve que c'est la première
fois en quinze ans de carrière que je
devais faire autant de rappels et
d'accompagnement intègre en son étoile
meli
gabriel collet est revenu au cégep juste
avant la pandémie après trois ans sur le
marché du travail et c'est parfait c'est
génial très motivé il a refait son cours
de chimie du secondaire pour être admis
en bioécologie mais la coved a cassé son
élan ya un moment où est ce que je me
suis demandée bon mais ce que je
continue vraiment ou non puis j'avais
vraiment je revends que la pandémie m'a
fait douter de savoir si j'allais
continuer encore
avec à l'appui
[Musique]
dorothée tanguay chante un succès
d'aretha franklin au festival arsène
organisé chaque été par le cégep de
drummondville
je veux aussi apporter mesdames et la
chanteuse va bientôt partir planter des
arbres en colombie britannique
après trois sessions en musique elle a
craqué donc je suis tombé comme une
grosse dépression
que moi je pense à
personne tellement joyeuse procession si
ça peut plancher
dorothée c'était bien adapté aux cours
virtuels le retour en classe l'automne
dernier at il beaucoup plus difficile
paul une très forte au chômage les
psychoéducateurs sont très sollicités
depuis septembre le retour en présentiel
et le débat sur le vaccin obligatoire
ont provoqué beaucoup d'anxiété mais
aussi la polarisation en lien avec le
statut vaccinal
certains étudiants s'inquiètent beaucoup
en lien avec ce parce qu'ils peuvent se
faire refuser des stages perdre leur
emploi remettre en question leurs
projets d'avenir dorothée qui n'est pas
vaccinée a vécu ce débat comme une
agression je me sens comme si j'étais
une tâche des fois je comprends pas le
monde me regarde plus encore
jamais eu ce but je trouve ça désolant
ça m'a mis un breton elle roule ça fait
pas qu autant émotionnellement que
physique marché chez pull l'étudiante a
besoin de temps pour reprendre des
forces mais elle n'abandonne pas elle
espère reprendre ses études quand les
soubresauts de la pandémie seront
apaisées
une réalisation importante gabriel qui a
failli décrocher du cégep une deuxième
fois pendant la pandémie puis et d'être
acceptée en biologie à l'université suis
vraiment fier et c'est sûr qu'avec un pc
d'amener ça fait 1 un défi de plus il y
avait à surmonter et monsieur jean
pierre davant terminée
à court terme c'est difficile c'est un
handicap est allison est généralement à
moyen long terme on sent grandi de ce et
on est capable de faire face à d'autres
adversité parce qu'on a de l'expérience
en arrière de nous on peut être se rend
compte que cette génération on va sortir
grandie du plus fort
[Musique]